Overwork in Japan is a real problem and a deadly one at that.
There is even a Japanese word for it,...
..."karoshi" meaning "death from overwork."
It's a problem that affects Japan's teachers in particular.
They are expected to not just teach their students...
...but also lead them during after-school activities,...
...cleaning duties and mentoring.
One investigation found school teachers...
...working an average of 123 hours overtime each month,...
...well above the government-defined karoshi line of 80 hours,...
...essentially meaning a high risk of death from overwork...
...if one works more than 80 overtime hours a month.
For some teachers, though, that risk does turn real.
A brain hemorrhage killed middle school teacher Yoshio Kudo in 2007...
...at just 40 years of age.
His diary entries told of a punishing workday that started early...
...and could last until nearly midnight.
Teachers are particularly vulnerable to karoshi.
A decades-old law essentially prevents them from being paid for overtime.
His widow, a former teacher herself,...
...says attitudes to karoshi need to change.
For about a year before he passed away,...
...he would often say how tired he was and how bad a headache he had...
...from when he moved to the new school in April until he died two months later.
He kept saying he was exhausted.
He said he wanted to leave the school.